neil young
rogan
beef yes if you want to call it that
yeah neil young basically said if
rogan's going to be on spotify
uh giving out misinformation with all
these doctors i don't want my music on
spotify so it's either me or him
yeah this is the perfect example of like
well we're talking about how people live
in their own bubbles you know like if al
baldwin can think that he's the most you
know famous successful actor in the
world then neil young can think anybody
gives a flying [ __ ] about his music i
can't name one neil young song yesterday
when i heard about the story i was so
upset because i thought sweet caroline
was a neil young song no it's a neil
diamond song yeah okay so i don't know a
single neil young song i don't care
about neil young i never thought about
it is that crosby stills nash and young
are those hockey players dude i have no
[ __ ] clue as you just said oh and
young's not with them no you are young
as part of it i'm correct yeah you just
said it crazy spacewise
what do you say um sweet caroline no
that's neil diamond that's neil diamonds
okay neil diamond saying that so i don't
know a single crosby nash stills and
young song i just know that's a group of
four people and then there's also neil
young is it the same young samuel
well let's put him on the list of neil's
where he is okay okay
diamonds
tyson neil [ __ ] him
neil
died armstrong armstrong okay okay okay
okay on the moon first person on the
move
wearing this watch right here there you
go okay omega there you go the omega
neil armstrong the omega okay number two
neil diamond diamond diamond gotta be
neil diamond yeah number three uh neil
patrick harris
jesus
um neil uh brennan neil brennan
neil
neil jordan who's that directed
interview with the vampire nope no no
gamer um neil gay man no gay man yeah
who's that um he wrote books good omens
is a show that just came out there's
another one uh [ __ ] it is about to know
him yeah sorry neil gaiman not there
colin kaepernick famously kneeled and
that's oh great neil
great kneeling i know that you didn't
say the other guy
come on come on now colin kaepernick
huge neil
huge
very true tim tebow another great meal
that's a good point another great deal
uh the thinking man oh yeah oh [ __ ]
atlas
uh other niels degrasse tyson we could
probably throw in there oh come on put
the goat in put the goat in there we'll
put i hate him negative nancy
but he is more famous than neil young
for sure can you put a family of famous
nails
okay go neil armstrong's brother
what's his name louie
dude louis armstrong this is an
interesting fact what's that louis
armstrong was actually supposed to go to
space
no really he was the one that was
supposed to go to space and there was a
mix-up what happened mix-up they had uh
it ended up being neil armstrong
wow
wow this is this is actually like a
weird story a lot of people don't know
this but um
so
louis armstrong yeah is
black yeah okay
everyone knows that i didn't yeah i did
not i was unaware they were worried they
would lose them in space oh my gosh they
were where they lose them in space
because you have to swim through space
no the jungle
the jumping dude they i mean if you saw
how high those white kids jumped on the
moon oh yeah they're like we don't have
a chance to pull them back down right
we're gonna have to do something we're
gonna have to have some sort of belt or
leash or something attach them to the
ship because if he takes one step the
guy's gonna be on jupiter yeah yeah yeah
yeah right is that why they sent only
white people to move for a long time 100
100 and you think they were also more
okay with like if white people died
that's fine yes yeah
it would be heroic yeah i think they
were trying to do it to protect some
black people i think that black lives
mattered back then
clearly mattered back then we can't risk
one of the greatest musicians of our
time
on this silly little space race yeah
stupid you know they should have sent
neil young
they absolutely should expendable
expendable absolutely hair wispy
dude his hair looks like um
like an asian man's chin
that's look at this [ __ ] guy dude
uh uh yeah he looks like a curmudgeon he
do look heller like donald trump
actually yeah why is he
side by side dude he looks like that uh
teacher with the mad eye moody yeah he
looks like
he does look like mad eye
it a little bit 100 dude this guy stinks
okay i just don't know why he thought he
was gonna win there's no way he thought
he'd spotify
take joe rogan's catalog down and keep
his when they got his catalog probably
for free and they paid nine figures for
joe rogan's kettlebell bro they
literally pay neil young pennies when
some old lady accidentally taps a
[ __ ] song thinking it's neil diamond
but some old lady pulls him up on her
[ __ ] junebug phone what is that it's
a big ass jitterbug oh my god i thought
you said some racist [ __ ] [ __ ] right
now no no jitterbug big-ass phone i
don't know what that is it's it's it's
it's
it's
it's
it's
it's
it's
it's
it's it's
it's
it's
it's
it's
it's
it's
it's
a whole bunch of jitterbug never seen a
journal
what is it it's awesome oh is that an
old joke
yeah maybe that would be nice um okay uh
the point is that neil young is uh
completely useless uh now i just yeah
there's gotta be a play right there's no
way he thought he was gonna want to
start a movement of people trying to
stand up against corporations that they
don't agree with i think he's trying to
like start like a little this is the
slow cut he's the rosa parks of
spotify
interesting opposite where he's going
i'm leaving immediately i'm off the bus
goes who where are you going i'm off the
bus name name a single
neil young song now go crosby steals
nash and youngs
that's not song
i want it i wish i had someone to throw
you there's people eating that they
don't have a song called crosby stills
nation young no right again forever
young
no young frankenstein that's alphaville
young at heart young young and close
you're so close long and restless
heart of gold young and wild and free
young wild and freeze fire he also he
also rode something
and it had no name oh
oh oh
name horse
rocking in the free world old man is
actually good that song is
maybe not two free maybe a world where
certain people specific people dictate
what information can go on spotify that
doesn't seem very free to me
what a piece of [ __ ] dude now some
people point out that neil young
survived polio as a child other people
point out that he might be a death eater
and he's actually inside a case
and if we look inside the case the real
neil young will be in there and be like
no let [ __ ] joe rogan do something
that must be what happened absolutely
dude the fact that his body was riddled
with polio yeah i mean like literally
like voldemort when he went to hogwarts
with polio
riddle guys guys guys
come on guys come on guys it just can't
just be me and miles oh yeah yeah can't
be just being me and miles out here
miles did you get it he thicker course
he got it immediately bro
this guy don't play games no but the
fact that he was riddled with polio as a
kid yeah does explain why his face looks
like [ __ ] in case
he does explain that like if you look at
his face your first reaction is like
[ __ ]
you look like oh that is my first
thought is whoa
whoa what happened here yeah
yeah personal name is a fun song is it
that's a funny singing
and then you come to the valley on a
horse with no name i don't know the rest
oh that one's yeah that one's like a
slap slaps that's laps i'll give him
that yeah they need to keep me along bro
what other songs does he have cosby
still's next old man look at my life
i don't know what that was no that one
was fire i don't know that one that was
kind of hot because it sounds like old
man look at his hands that sounds like
that sounds like it's
how he sounds oh yeah yeah that sucks
whatever you're just saying sucked no
that was a good one no no bro ain't no
horses no no oh man
hey you know we could get these two
songs we like itunes for 99 cents yeah
that's a good point you think that's
worth spotify being like hey joe
get out of here yeah i don't think so i
mean buddy where is your leverage
point his leverage is that he doesn't
care about streaming and like getting
money from spotify okay and then he off
spotify yeah spotify made the choice bye
bye
exactly so he wasn't on spotify for a
super long time because he was like oh
the streaming's unfair and
then
and then he acquiesced didn't he and
then he was like all right fine i'll put
him yeah yeah and now he's trying to
back out with morality again get out of
here buddy
hit the bricks what if this becomes a
trend and now actual artist that people
care about start doing that won't happen
who's the first artist that would
wait what who's the first artist that
would join along well you know who did
this first
uh garth brooks
i don't think he's available on any
streaming yeah i think you have to like
buy his financial play right it's not a
vaccine play yeah
political oh
like a joe rogan statement uh uh uh uh i
don't think artists will do this
nobody is canceling their spotify
because neil young is off
it's just not you know what it would
take for me to cancel my spotify what or
i don't think there's a single artist
that they got off spotify i'd be like
i'm canceling my subscription all right
guys we're gonna take a break from this
exclusive patreon clip because i gotta
tell y'all about the best wallets in the
game and those wallets come from extra
okay extra the world's largest smart
wallet brand they design innovative
solutions to improve the way that you
carry your everyday items okay first of
all we got the quick card access did you
see how quick them cards just popped out
so i could access them every card you
need right at your fingertips all right
it's that easy hit that little button
right there they all slide up you pay
for your things they also have the cr
the key tracker features they are
trackable worldwide that means you could
track this wallet worldwide you are not
going to lose it okay voice activated as
well if you lose your wallet just call
it it works from google home alexa and
siri and remember it is solar powered
two hours of sunlight gives you up to
three months of charge that is huge okay
because i know you're thinking where do
i charge my wallet you don't have to
you're just putting that [ __ ] out there
in the sun simple as that extra offers
smart solutions to improve how you carry
your everyday essentials their wallets
offer sleek alternative bulky dad
wallets you do not need them so check
out the wallets at exeter.com and use
the code flagrant at checkout for 30 off
your order that is e k s t e r dot com
and the offer code is flagrant for 30
off your order now let's get back to
this exclusive patreon clip you can
watch the whole episode and many more
at patreon.com flagrant2 i need y'all to
explain this whole jake paul uh
endeavor thing
because everybody's making it out like
jake paul is an owner of endeavor i
don't know that's the thing they don't
know how much he owns well let me just
explain so it's like wme
william morris endeavor is an agency
that bought the ufc
yeah so he invested in that agency it's
a publicly traded agency so
apparently he invested enough where he
has like some seats
i think that's what he claimed or like
his partner claims that he would get
four board seats he has four board seats
i don't know how much you have to invest
it seems like you have to invest
something significant maybe we can look
into that a little bit more
and the way it's being positioned is
because of this he's dana's boss because
dana is technically managing the company
for william morris endeavor now
i can't fathom that he was
able to buy enough of
william morris endeavor yeah where
he could have influence in the company
yeah
this i ca now technically everybody who
owns that stock is an owner of william
morris endeavor and if you want to say
dana's boss then sure yeah but i can't
fathom that they won the one he could
afford to buy that much of it and two
that they would even allow it they got
to know that that's going to piss off
dana so what could have happened is the
guy he partnered with has a lot of money
bought a lot you put a little bit in
i'll say we partnered doesn't matter how
much you partnered oh but i'm curious
how many board seats there are and is
for a significant share are there a
hundred board seats and four is nothing
interesting
interesting yeah there's a thousand
board members and you have four seats
who gives a [ __ ] yeah
but if there's 20 board seats and you
got four of them oh now you're doing
something now you got 20 of this thing
so he partnered with a guy he partnered
with a guy his business partner had a
series of tweets about how this is the
best way to move the company forward in
the long term is paying people more etc
but uh he could have just brought jake
paul in him and like yo let's make some
noise you're gonna get this good
publicity i'm my name's gonna get out
there in the same way that owning a team
puts you in a like if you own a sports
franchise your name is suddenly a very
exclusive name you get that notoriety
right he's a billionaire they all want
that so hey i'm gonna get some notoriety
off you get some publicity your partner
just give me a hundred thousand give me
a million give me whatever
and then we'll say we both own it and
we're both fighting for this thing it's
mutually beneficial interesting but i am
curious how much ford board seats is
yeah we have to figure that out another
thing is what do you think about jake
paul versus francis and ghana
oh yeah that'd be crazy yeah would be
good
why because jake paul can probably
outbox francis but if francis hits him
once is over
now francis used to be a boxer oh i
didn't think he has a boxing background
i think maybe he'd be good
uh but still like that'd be a crazy
fight
yeah i mean i think jake loses that i
mean that's jake's last fight yeah
absolutely get paid lose be done yeah
and it's actually kind of like win-win
for everybody because the payday would
be absolutely [ __ ] massive
and for both people and then it would
put francis back in dana white's good
graces
because he got
jake out of here what about francis
versus logan would that be more fun
i i think that i think logan has to be
in the position where he's the hero
he's the face
right so whoever he fights we want to
see him get knocked out and they don't
have to be a person that's an actual
boxer it could be like a youtube celeb
or something like that but somebody that
like we just don't like
and then logan comes and saves the day i
think he's much better presented as that
whereas jake is the villain
and people are paying to see him get
knocked out so who's the person that you
actually think is going to do it now and
francis would probably knock him out i
can't yeah i mean francis has a boxing
background i don't know ufc at all i
thought yes was it well you started as a
boxer then learned the other things
so he could be in ufc um
interesting though
yeah i can't imagine that like jake
paul's acquisition is actually
the way it's being presented it's also
like he's not even speaking out that
much it's mostly his business partner
that's like putting out all the
information about it yeah there's no way
yeah but yeah and i can't imagine that
yeah like you were saying that they
would be cool with it knowing the public
beef between dana they know how
important dana is to that company yeah
you know he's the ambassador yeah like
there's certain companies that have a
ceo that you just don't know anything
about but he's part of the celebrity ceo
brigade yep you know it's him elon bezos
zuckerberg and whoever but they
understand the value in being famous and
how you can use that value to build your
company and he does it probably better
than that well elon's probably the best
but like
the best yeah he does it better than
most so it's like having dana be pissed
off and then removed like you're crazy
if you do that matter of fact you gotta
beg him to stay once this contract is
over yeah you have to back you need him
yeah what i'm assuming you happen is he
probably has like either some vc he's
working with or his business partner
that has just like a bankroll invested a
bunch of money into wme and then
now they're just using that story as
like
you know like a leveraged play to dana
and like trying to piss him off and then
the board seats thing is disputed back
and forth yeah let's wait to see that i
haven't seen anyone confirm that from
like a reputable source yeah i think he
just threw that out there and they maybe
were like in talks to like negotiate
that or like he yeah put a message out
like yo we want board seats but nobody
cares about the truth the lie is more
interesting yeah and that is by once
yeah you could buy one share of a
company and be invited to there yeah
exactly their annual meeting yeah
so kind of a smart like social play i
think oh brilliant i mean he just knows
how to do it like jake has gone from
heel to hero in legit 30 days yeah he
knocked out uh was his name woodley a
month ago and he everybody hated him
whatever and then all of a sudden he
pivoted to you know what i just want
these fighters get paid better and he
knocked out woodley legit so you're like
oh this guy can box for real yeah you
know he's fighting for a fighter pay
good for him yeah heal the hero in 30
days it's unbelievable yeah you don't
want him on your ass especially if
you're not in the social game as well no
like that [ __ ] is just
relentless yeah non-stop
cooking up content on your [ __ ] ass
yeah
so i'm curious if dana even responds i
think he's realized that his time
responding is is
past him yeah
and i think he's realizing that like by
responding he only blows it up more yeah
so just keep on putting on great fight
cards keep the conversation a bit about
the company and not reacting to these
things and if i'm him i'm telling all
the journalists to show up don't ask me
about this [ __ ] like i don't
want to ask and answer any questions
about this yep
now i don't know if he has that kind of
control but
because he can't avoid it
because then he looks like he's in his
feelings
it's just got to appear as if it doesn't
exist what up people you just watch a
clip from our weekly patreon episode you
can support the flagrancy you can
support this unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join you should because it's a top 10
patreon in the [ __ ] world that's
right for a good reason go check out why
at patreon.com flagrant2
all right peace
you